let's talk about various strategies that
you can do to stop over eating
or should we say stop eating like a pig
like this
[Music]
so there's just a few problems with
overeating of course um
you know you have overeating of the
wrong foods and overeating of just
healthy foods right which then can
create a big strain on your digestive
system
being satisfied is a very subjective
thing and it's difficult because
sometimes the food that they're eating
is not satisfying them for certain
reasons and we're going to talk about
that so what is the right amount to eat
so you don't overdo it that's the big
question now in Okinawa they have a very
good principle that they follow of
course we're talking about the
traditional people probably not the
current people that are kind of more
modern
but traditionally they eat until they're
about 80 percent full I think that gives
some nice leeway there and I like that
principle if you can do it so ultimately
the best thing you can do for this
problem is to not have an appetite and
not have any Cravings right if you can
do that then everything's going to be
easier and of course the way to do that
is to get on the healthy version of Keto
okay where you're doing high quality
nutrient dense foods that's satisfying
you on one end and then also you're
doing low carbs which uh will greatly
reduce the hunger in between eating and
also when you're doing intermittent
fasting your stomach does change because
you're not eating so frequently and the
amount of food that you eat is going to
be less because you can't just fit all
that food in there like you did before
especially if you're doing things like
eating one meal a day you're just not
going to be able to cram that much food
it's going to be uncomfortable it's
going to be painful and so you're not
going to keep doing it typically when
you're craving certain foods that could
just be a low blood sugar situation
where you're trying to maintain this
level of glucose or the storage of
glucose in your liver called glycogen
and so you have to constantly eat
something more on the carbohydrate side
but you also have people that crave
bread could mean they might need more B
vitamins people that crave just sugar it
could potentially mean that they need
more potassium possibly probably not but
it could be or if you crave chocolate
that could mean that you need more
magnesium and of course if you're
craving dirt that classically means that
you need more iron or even if you crave
Dairy it could mean that you need more
calcium I intuitively can just know what
to eat if I go to a grocery store okay
or on a given day before I eat I can
pretty much know what my body needs
more of and because I'm in keto and for
some reason I can just gravitate to
certain foods more than other foods like
I'll need a lot more celery other times
I'll need more protein so you do want to
get to a point where you're really in
tune with your own body but the worst
question you can ever ask is hmm
what is my body in the mood for today
popcorn Pizza chips cookies
don't ever ask that question okay a
better question would be what can I eat
that's truly going to make my body
healthier but of course you really have
to be keto adapted or fat adapted to ask
the question or you're just constantly
running into this
low energy low sugar blood sugar
situation there is actually
um and I've learned this just recently
there are certain genes that you can
have a an issue with that can cause you
to have more of a sweet tooth and that
can cause you to not be able to stop
eating certain things when you start
eating certain things and that is one of
my problems if I start eating sugar I
can't stop I will just eat massive
amounts the same thing with
carbohydrates so I just don't start but
I think the worst factor to this topic
is restaurants especially the all you
can eat buffets right where you really
want to get your money's worth and you
keep going back and back and it's like
why do we have to stuff our body with
that much food it's just insane there
are certain foods especially in America
that give you much larger portions than
you really need okay huge steaks like 12
ounce steaks do you really need to eat
that much protein and then of course the
pasta and then of course the dessert
right I have found in Europe their
serving sizes are much less there are
certain restaurants that will have these
small portions but it'll be many of
those so in one restaurant and I'm not
kidding they gave us 11
of these
these plates okay it was small but after
the seventh meal I was just hoping it
was going to be done because it was not
pleasurable it was just sampling after
sampling after sampling so I think one
really good tip is just to really
determine how much food you're going to
eat and then the next day you end up
with blood sugar problems because you
raise your insulin up okay and now
you're craving the wrong thing and then
you also have the factor that you must
eat everything on your plate because
people are starving in other places of
the world and we just have to just
finish our plate and so if that's the
case just keep your portions on the
smaller side so there are hormones that
increase your appetite make you hungry
and there's hormones that make you full
okay or satisfied and the hormones that
make you hungry we'll talk about that
first include ghrelin insulin and
cortisol the stress hormone so ghrelin
that hunger hormone is triggered by
various things uh one would be the lack
of sleep right I know with myself if I
don't get enough sleep
I definitely have more of an appetite
stress is another Factor when you're
under stress you're going to crave more
food and also when you eat refined
carbohydrates that's going to tend to
lack those factors that are supposed to
satisfy you and eating refined
carbohydrates can also stimulate that
hormone but when someone's actually
stressed they're really not in the
present and especially if they're in a
social environment
where they'll just do things that they
don't normally do because you're not
really in the present they get into this
certain mode and they just start eating
and they really don't differentiate what
they're eating and then next thing you
know you just are completely off your
plan now with insulin of course that is
another hormone that stimulates hunger
doesn't matter what you're eating well
Spike insulin which will make you more
hungry about an hour and a half later
especially if you're doing those snacks
okay of course carbohydrates and also
larger amounts of protein and MSG can
also increase insulin and Trigger hunger
and of course there's cortisol and if
you're more stressed you're going to eat
more of certain things and the wrong
things and also it's interesting people
that are on a diet they tend to get off
sugar but sometimes they'll have
artificial sweeteners well artificial
sweeteners can also stimulate hunger
which is interesting because it can
potentially stimulate insulin now other
things that could stimulate appetite
a lack of bile in your gallbladder let's
say for example you have gallstones
which means you're lacking a bile that
thing that helps you dissolve fat and
extract fat soluble vitamins from your
meal let's say you had the gallbladder
removed okay chances are you're going to
be lacking bile or any type of problem
with the liver or tightness underneath
the right rib cage some pain that goes
on the right side all those are subtle
indicators that you are deficient in
bile and so if you're not absorbing
certain fats that can keep you from
being satisfied you will feel full but
you won't be satisfied so that will
trigger
eat more and by the way the way to
handle that is just to take bile salts
after the meal take one and that will
help being on a low-fat diet okay can
definitely keep your hunger up fat is
very satisfying
I do recommend being on the ketogenic
diet to eat more fat especially after
the meal okay and then that way uh you
can fast longer and that can help you
now junk food okay especially these
refined carbohydrates at any grocery
store you'll have all these flavored
chips which are loaded with chemicals
incredible flavors and spices but no
real nutrients behind it and you'll just
keep tasting these and you'll just keep
doing boy these are delicious but
there's no satisfaction so you can eat
the whole thing of course manufacturing
companies do this on purpose so you know
that but if I buy a bag of Doritos I
cannot just have one right I'll eat the
whole darn thing and then I want another
one and another one so you just have to
avoid those areas on the grocery store
or at some other place that they would
sell them another reason why people will
overeat
is to get energy because they're tired
they will satisfy this tired feeling
they tend to reach for more food to
replace this fatigue to hopefully get
more energy okay so that's another
reason why people will eat certain foods
of course
that food that they just ate or over ate
they're going to be tired shortly after
that you also have people eating out of
boredom boy that's a it's a big one you
know you're sitting around the house and
you just are bored so you eat you really
don't have any reason you're not hungry
you just like to chew on chips not
necessarily celery
but something crunchy like nuts like
pistachio or something like that now if
someone's pregnant and they're craving
certain things hopefully they're on the
ketogenic diet that could definitely
mean that the baby needs certain things
so just make sure you have something
nutrient dense and also then some people
will eat because they're in pain as some
way to actually get them out of pain
right so there's a lot of reasons why
people will eat now let's talk about the
other hormone called leptin that is
supposed to satisfy you so if leptin is
too low okay you can also be hungry
and people that are overweight people
that have insulin resistance people that
have metabolic syndrome people that um
have diabetes have low levels of leptin
okay so they're going to be hungrier
versus all of those people that I just
mentioned are going to have higher
amounts of insulin so hormonally
things are against them and it's going
to be more difficult if you don't have
enough of that leptin uh you just you're
not going to be satisfied too well so
let's talk about those things that can
increase leptin other than losing weight
fixing your insulin resistance and
getting rid of your diabetes a good
night's rest can help you raise your
leptin lowering stress can help you
routine regular exercise or physical
activity can help increase leptin adding
more fiber can help you increase leptin
and I'm not talking about these
functional food fibers these new ones
I'm talking about the actual vegetables
another thing that can increase leptin
is fasting right now at first when you
do fasting you're going to be hungry but
then your body's going to convert over
you're going to burn fat and so now
you're doing intermittent fasting and
now your appetite goes away and your
leptin can start to reverse and start to
be increased okay and this is the best
indicator that to know that you're
burning fat okay that you're in ketosis
is that you lose the appetite and of
course if you lose the appetite your
leptin is going to be higher omega-3
fatty acids can help increase leptin
green tea can help increase leptin
probiotics and fermented foods but the
microbial density can help increase
leptin and make you more satisfied just
nutrient dense foods in general can make
you more satisfied now the research on
this is sketchy but I know for a fact I
live on a farm when I consume the eggs
for my chickens
boy I am satisfied compared to other
eggs when I consume the the meat from my
own Farm
super satisfying so what's causing that
is it the fat is it the protein is it
the carbs
no it's the nutrients it's nutrient
dense so most people Americans
especially are just eating empty
calories and that is going to keep them
eating over and over and just make them
always hungry which is terrible if
you're trying to do any type of diet or
trying to achieve any type of Health
goal so to get out of this pattern of
overeating you want to get on the
healthy version of Keto and definitely
do intermittent fasting I also recommend
that you eat your vegetables first okay
and that way at least you can get a lot
of really low calorie fiber and
nutrients first and that's going to help
definitely just with feeling full as you
eat the next meal versus the protein
which
tends not to turn off that hunger as
much so eat your vegetables first
also before you eat determine what
you're going to eat and how much you're
going to eat and then that way you can
control what you eat and we're talking
about moderate amounts of protein
between three four five six maybe seven
ounces of protein if you're going to do
salad it's seven to ten cups but of
course if you're doing two meals right
you would cut that in half it's doable
and then of course the fat that comes
with that protein now I also add extra
fat like whether it's going to be pecans
or macadamia nuts or maybe an avocado
olive oil maybe a keto dessert I'll add
more butter to the meal the other thing
to do to kind of keep you conscious
and in in the moment okay is to chew
your food uh longer right uh so many
people have watched them eat and they
just like inhale the food and it's like
there's a Race So chew your food
thoroughly before you eat okay that'll
help your digestion and then I think the
restaurants they're a bit dangerous if
you don't go to the right restaurant
don't go to all you can eat buffets make
sure that you kind of stay in control of
your meal at a restaurant you know they
bring in all these uh these Breads and
hors d'oeuvres so just be really
conscious of what you're putting in your
mouth and the size of those Foods at the
restaurants especially if you're doing
them frequently so this topic was all
about not overeating but I think it's
very important to know what to eat okay
what meal would be the healthiest meal
and I put that video up right here check
it out